inches should be any different i will  say i think the press conferences can be  done a lot better i still think some of  the questions are very amateurish and  terrible actually especially from the  non-chess um  experienced journalists the more the  more sort of legacy media journalists  so i think the i think the press  conference yeah how do you feel  about this move well it was the biggest  blunder of my life so how do you think  but i need to support those guys because  you know the people my level in  journalism i don't understand so we want  to sort of our  feelings behind it i do understand but i  think there's a way you can